françois perrot les téléspectateurs vous
connaissent bien les cinéphiles
également vous avez tourné déjà beaucoup
de films la dernière série télévisée qui
a beaucoup frappé le téléspectateur
s'était passé d'ailleurs chez nos amis
d'antenne 2 c'était et dames de la côte
vous fait ce métier depuis déjà
longtemps
j'aimerais savoir comment vous êtes
entré dans cet univers si compliqué si
difficile que celui du métier de
comédienne nous appartenait à une
famille d'artistes
on n'a pas du tout non non non pas du
tout j'étais j'ai commencé j'étais jeune
j'étais ébéniste à l'étranger faire et
j'étais à l'école boulle j'ai fait trois
ans quatre ans d'école boom et puis on
sait par hasard je suis entré dans le
métier et vous en avez vécu correctement
tout de suite perdu tous nos jeux
regarder à côté votre pas encore bien
maintenant vous garder de côté l'atelier
d'ébéniste et non faut beaucoup d'argent
pour être ministre oui oui qu'est-ce que
ce métier vous apporter comme
satisfaction comme déception jusqu'à
maintenant vous avez tourné avec
beaucoup de gens vous ai fait des films
très intéressant l'argent des autres
séries modem le jul tournée des costa
gavras
moi tout ce que j'ai fait ma m'a fait
plaisir parce que toute façon toute
façon on me fait plaisir quoi qu'elle
est l'inquiéter d'un comédien qui
travaillent dans des conditions c'est
les sujets qui sont pas toujours très
bon la recherche permanente d'une
histoire d'une histoire originale d'un
scénario costaud que tu ais je vais vous
dire je crois que les gens ne va pas une
légende mais enfin on part du principe
que les comédiens doivent choisir le
scénario mais c'est pas aux comédiens de
choisir cette gens qui les produisent et
comédien il faut qu'ils travaillent dire
que il m'arrive de d'accepter des
scénarios qui sont qui sont pas très
bons mais mais il faut et il faut vivre
nommé galabru nous l'a dit il ya quinze
jours
voilà les raisons c'est à dire que
c'est à dire que c'est ça les gens vous
disent tiens souvent en effet vous ne
pouvez pas accepter tel était le sujet
mais moi je dis que faut se débrouiller
avec ce qu'on a qua non des fois ça
tombe bien
comme avec philippe et puis les x bah
c'est pas me sais pas c'est pas ce n'est
pas embêtant d'être mis à mal un peu
dans la vie que de vivre de façon pure
comme ça en faisant que ce qui est beau
prépare que c'est un sujet que vous me
disiez un petit mot de ce film de votre
rôle
il m'a eu à ymare qui m'a dit une chose
ces e-mails parce qu'il m'a dit un
moment donné ce type là il fait une
gaffe de vieux et ça s'est trouvé ça
très joli et alors j'ai fait ça pour ça
que je peux soit parce qu'il est venu me
voir de beaux yeux
d'abord il s'est déplacé pour venir chez
moi hein ça j'ai été très touchée ça se
passe pas souvent c'est souvent les
comédiens qui font d'antichan mais qui
n'arrivent pas à quoi ces metteurs en
scène c'est rare qu'un metteur en scène
vient voir un comédien je suis bien
compris oui c'est assez rare c'est assez
rare la courtoisie c'est assez rare
[Musique]